you always find him
Around The Christmas Tree stop it
cardi B gives fans an inside look at her
holiday decor and its Christmas goals
people
on Monday the rapper posted these clips
to Instagram showing off a few of the
different Christmas trees in her home
including a Disney themed tree for the
kiddos complete with red accents candy
canes large shiny bulbs and a few
characters like Mickey Minnie and Goofy
so this is the kids Christmas tree
oh
it's huge
and it's um
it's Disney themed hey
hey stop running
it's beautiful
stop running
around the Christmas trees listen with a
gorgeous tree like that I tell the kids
to stop running around the house too duh
those kiddos are the two bundles of Joy
cardi shares with her hubby offset 13
month old Sun wave and a four-year-old
daughter culture I love everything about
motherhood and fans got a glimpse at
Little Wave hanging out by the adult
trees yeah trees as in multiple
Christmas trees and this is a wavy boy
yep that's waving his jammies smiling
ear to ear really feeling that holiday
spirit stop me and doing what kids do
making mom nervous around all the
fragile ornaments
this is
Christmas tree
[Music]
I wish everything was Christmas
clearly cardi is feeling the Christmas
spirit too captioning the post quote the
tree up beautiful huh
beautiful of course cardi is famous for
going all out for the holidays oh yes
honey on Halloween the family dressed to
the max rocking Batman themed costumes
offset and wave as the Joker cardi as
Batman and culture as Harley Quinn and
culture she knows how to pose it up for
the cameras just like her famous mom
cardi shared those Halloween snaps a
month after the holiday alongside a
sweet message of gratitude on
Thanksgiving quote grateful for my
family thank you Lord for changing my
life around it's like a feeling that
it's undescribable it's like love joy
it's a switch and back in September the
lovebirds celebrated their son's first
birthday with an extravagant car themed
Bash
okay anyway okay
offset opened up about why they pull out
all the stops for special occasions if
you love our kids you want to have a
good time and bring our family together
we travel a lot we'd be gone a lot so we
bring our family together make it a big
celebration for the kid even though he
won you know at the end of the day we
went through life and we didn't have
opportunities I bet if my mama had a
chance she would have did went all out
and did what she wanted to do for me so
just letting them see that they can have
another life too you know we work hard
to do that
[Music]
thank you